welcome to episode 126 of film courage
my name is Karen warden my name is David
Brannon and I'm not only doing the radio
show them tweeting at the same time
Karen wow that's attached because I'm
just having fun here our guest today his
Doug block doug is a documentary
filmmaker living in New York City and
founder of the d-word community a site
for documentary filmmakers which he
founded in nineteen ninety nine Doug's
documentary credits as director include
51 birch Street home page and the heck
with Hollywood his documentary producing
credits include Silver Lake life
Jupiter's wife love and Diane paternal
instinct American harmony a walk into
the sea Danny Williams and the Warhol
Warhol factory Doug's latest film a
personal documentary about his
relationship with his daughter called
the kids grew up was broadcast on HBO on
Father's Day 2011 after a limited
theatrical release and is now available
on DVD and go get that DVD doug is also
a producer of a me hardies documentary
feature the edge of dreaming and he's
the executive producer of John Foy's
resurrect dead the mystery of the I hope
I'm saying this right the Toynbee tiles
which won the Best Director award in the
u.s. documentary competition at this
past sun dance 2011 Doug also dabbles in
blogging on around the block Doug blocks
dock blog just that easy I tried I
practiced in the car coming over here to
support his documentary habit Doug also
makes verte style wedding videos and
consults with other filmmakers on their
documentary please welcome to film
courage via Skype mr. Doug block welcome
Doug hello no it's nice being here oh
great well you can hear me yes loud and
clear and you sound good here Doug you
sound good Thanks yes thank you for
joining us if you had two 21 year old
aspiring filmmakers come to you one who
had been making short movie since the
age of 10 11 12 13 years of age and then
you had the other one who was just sort
of catching
the filmmaking bug and they both put in
some serious thought and they both
decided hey you know what I'm going to
be a filmmaker and then they and then
each of these guys or ladies come to you
for guidance would you give them both
the same advice and what would you tell
them that's a good question a really
good question you know I mean I work in
the documentary realm so you know any
kind of advice I pretty much give for
documentary filmmakers although I
suppose a good part of it might apply to
to fiction filmmakers that's part of it
i mean i don't know that there'd be a
whole lot of difference I think you know
we live in a wonderful age certainly for
making documentaries and films of all
kinds in that that the means of
production is is so much simpler and
easier and cheaper so you know anybody
can really leap in and start making a
film these days you know it used to be
you had to have those years of wanting
to do it I think to kind of have the
courage to put the money and be when it
was so expensive to shoot on film but
now you know you can get the bug last
week and order you know a camera for a
thousand bucks in high-def sure and go
out and shoot a feature film for next to
nothing so I think that whole entry bar
has been lowered I think the thing that
distinguishes everyone is is are you are
you in it for the long haul hmm you know
are you willing to stick to it when
suddenly you know you get to that other
phase of trying to raise money for the
back end of the film for the for the
editing and for the you know all these
hidden costs that are involved and then
getting it through to distribution and
then once you go through but getting
getting your first film made are you
willing to stick in it for the second
and the third not keeping that Darwinian
theory of sort of a survival of the
fittest what do you think are the things
that where the people start dropping off
what is it is it that that constant you
no need for more money to finish for
post-production what do you think deters
people in the end I think a lot of it is
you know we go into our first film
thinking
you know we're gonna get this great
success we have this dream of what
success looks like and oftentimes it's
you know kind of hitting it big with
your first film you go to Sundance and
some distributor loves your film and all
you know there's a bidding war they all
offer you a ton of money and you know
you you you break in a in a very large
way and that happens to one in a
thousand filmmakers you know and the
hard part is you know do you have what
it takes to stick in there even when you
don't catch a kind of lightning in the
bottle um which happens to so few films
well is it realistic for for filmmakers
independent filmmakers to think that
they can make a living off of their
dreams probably not but you know since
when is realism come into this you know
I mean I think you have to be kind of
diluted to think that you're gonna beat
the odds and your film is going to get
out there the kind of visibility that
you always hope for you know I mean just
think about how many people submit their
films to the top tier festivals and then
how many actually get in and then once
they get in how many were there actually
get on the radar of you know the
mainstream public very very few so you
have to be wildly deluded to do this and
to think that you can make a good living
doing it you know is really delusional
but you know I i I'm saying this more I
think as a documentary filmmaker where
you know careers aren't sustained the
system doesn't work to sustain careers
in the way that fiction films do when
they're successful I think you know
between agents and distributors and the
press we're always looking for the who's
the next big thing in the fiction world
and I don't think people look at
documentaries they look at on a
case-by-case basis is this film urgent
and timely and important and they don't
think about you know who doesn't this
filmmaker deserve to be no supported for
their
next film whereas in fiction film I
think it's all about your next work and
discovering who's talented and who who
we can come in and work with them and
support well let's go to your personal
story so what led you to a camera in the
first place and what draws you to
documentary filmmaking oh it's a long
story so I'll try and connect to the
chase as best I can I mean I did a
little bit of everything I didn't go to
film school I went to Cornell which
happens to have a really strong
exhibition program where they play just
have a fantastic program of exhibiting
you know the best of all kinds of cinema
and I went all the time during my four
years of college and came out I think
with this you know kind of an intuitive
feel for moviemaking but there's no set
path to directing to you know and and I
took whatever odd jobs i could for a
number of years just wanted to be on
movie sets learn as much as I could and
kind of path kind of started taking me
towards editing which I actually highly
recommend for anybody who wants to be a
director it's kind of the core of
filmmaking and an opportunity came up to
shoot it was very fluky and I basically
lied to the producer and said I do had a
shoot I didn't and I fake my way through
is kind of what happened and next thing
I know a month staff at Newsweek when
they had a broadcasting arm and for the
next three years I shot every day and
why why do you think you were able to
stick their Doug stick there at-at yeah
years yeah you said you kind of faked
your way through it but but obviously
they were there was some some talent
behind what you were doing well you know
strange as it seems because I had very
little camera experience even as a still
photographer I think watching so many
movies gave me this inherent feel for
composition and for you know just where
a camera should be you know what point
you should get in close
what point you pull back wide and to get
things like cutaways and you know I
think I think one big mistake that a lot
of beginning filmmakers make is that
they shoot particularly in documentaries
as they shoot everything in medium shot
it just kind of follow the action from a
set distance and they forget to kind of
come in for close-ups and go wide for
establishing shots and you know that's
that's the vocabulary the basic
vocabulary of cinema so I think it's III
was just very lucky and I discovered I
kind of picked up a lot of that stuff I
mean I was not very strong with lighting
and but you know you can go to courses
there weekend courses or their summer
courses or night courses that you can
take and pick up some of the more
technical things like that but you know
and I have a friend who teaches editing
is always saying that you know what he
teaches is not how you make a cut but
why you make a cut and that's what I
would you know distinguish between I
learned how to kind of why you make cuts
how was easier you know as I listened to
it almost sounds like filmmaking found
you just as much as you found it yeah I
think I'd often happens I mean you see a
movie and you fall you fall crazy in
love you know for me it was Citizen Kane
you know Here I am a documentary
filmmaker but it was Citizen Kane that
got me you know so excited about the
potential of moviemaking and made me
feel like I want to be one of those guys
behind the camera you know who who
creates the shots and that was when I
was like 16 or 17 years old so I knew I
knew on the spot that's what I wanted to
do did I go to film school now because
you know well that's another long story
you know and i don't i don't know that
anybody really has to i mean i know
there's certain advantages of doing it
but you know I think you just have to
love movies and you wanna you know
they're there there are other ways of
studying how to do it and a lot of a lot
of people now just go out and make them
and that
it's not a bad way to learn it could be
an expensive way to learn but you know
let's talk about you being behind the
camera you know and two of your your
recent documentaries which I have
garnered a lot of a claim 51 bird street
which is about your parents and then you
have the kids grow up which is about
your daughter so here you are you have
two documentaries about your family you
know what why did you feel that these
two stories were to that you had to tell
and was it difficult turning the camera
on your loved ones neither are simple
have simple answers but 51 birch trees
is a film I never intended to make I
mean I you kind of got to be crazy to
think there's a film in your parents
marriage I mean to this day I'm sort of
astonished that it happened and it and
it and it landed so successfully really
all over the world which I guess you
know tells you that the the most you
know oftentimes the most universal
stories or the are the really particular
ones and in this case it was about my
family and it look you know my I thought
my parents had a very normal kind of
reasonably happy marriage of 54 years
that I never really questioned and
nobody really questioned and then three
months after my mother died kind of
unexpectedly my father called we lived
in the I grew up in New York and my
father called from Florida not I didn't
even know he was down there and he
announced that he was moving in with his
secretary from 40 years ago and we kind
of got over the shock of that but they
married they sold the family house and
when I went out there for the last time
I think about two weeks before the
movers came I discovered among many
other things three large cartons filled
with my mother's Diaries going all the
way back to that time 40 years ago so it
you know it brought up all these
questions
what had been going on in my family and
and and once I opened the dyers in
particular you know it's like Pandora's
Box opened and every assumption that i
had about our our family was called into
question and even it even then at first
I wasn't going to make didn't see this
as a movie a moment happened I was
talking to my father and he revealed
just how unhappy he was in the marriage
and you know in that second i went from
not making a film to making a film and i
had two weeks to shoot it you know and
of course filling in some other stuff
but so it was definitely a film that
found me and you know of course once I
got in it I dome into it and you kind of
have to feel like there's some aspect of
the story that's universal to do such a
personal film and I latched onto this
idea that you know how well do we really
know our parents and given the
opportunity how well would we really
want to know our parents hmm it's a
really intriguing couple of questions
there because you know as we get older
and become adults and even parents
ourselves you know on one hand we want
to have a more adult relationship with
our parents at the same time you're
always the kid and you always want your
mommy and daddy to be a certain way and
it's you know it's a really intriguing
conflict and the other thing that
happened was my father had started it's
not the kind of guy who talked a lot of
it himself and all of a sudden he was
opening up and answering my questions
really openly and honestly and now
within that two-week period our entire
relationship changed 180 degrees which
is something that's rarely seen in a
documentary you know it's the stuff of
fiction film so I mean it's interesting
that personal documentaries about one's
family can seem you know self-indulgent
or narcissistic
or you know such a small topic and yet
you know if you look at hollywood movies
you know some of the biggest Hollywood
movies you know that's the subject of
many of them many of the classics are
about family dynamics so you know it's
just kind of an interesting perception
difference well you talked about two in
the trailer for a 51 bird street that
were only as sick as our secrets and I
know that's a sing-off her before I'm
wondering though did anyone try to talk
you out of doing the film I mean you had
that two-week window were there people
that that tried to tell you not to do it
no no I mean I my family is used to me
shooting around them I mean not that I I
think there's a misperception from the
kids grow up that for instance you know
I spent my entire daughter's life
shooting her on camera which is hardly
the truth you know but you know I would
take the camera out periodically family
gatherings of almost every sort you know
even if only for like ten minutes and
over the years everybody kind of you
know they make a face of verse and then
they get completely used to me doing it
and you know basically ignore me so it's
a documentary filmmakers dream to have
that kind of access and willingness and
you know my family's really comfortable
on camera there they're kind of
comfortable being themselves and you
know it's just something I picked up on
over the years so I you know the other
thing is you know you're shooting on a
camera they all now of course and have
for the past 10 15 years started looking
like camcorders these digital cameras
these now high def cameras still look an
awful lot like just a plain old
camcorder so you know my family sees me
whip out the camcorder they don't kind
of connect it to you know their son or
their husband or their father you know
who makes these movies that end up on
big screens and play on places like HBO
they just see me doing you know what
seems to be the whole movie thing so
know the answer the question is no
pretty gave me a heart
I'm nobody knew what I was really doing
with 51 bird street the kids grow up was
very different because at that point you
know they'd seen 51 bird street and it's
very different asking your daughter to
be part of this kind of film than it is
your you know your aging parents or
parent well when we spoke to a filmmaker
Todd Hickey about integrity in
documentary filmmaking he mentioned that
you know as a filmmaker you're looking
for the truth but if you push the
subject or if you edit too far you may
hurt someone's feelings and in this case
with working with people that are your
family how are you able to walk that
fine line or because they were so used
to having that camera around that you
kind of got beyond that well there's a
difference between shooting and editing
and I think those those kinds of I mean
you know there's a certain ethics to
shooting which is you don't force
anybody to you know be on camera when
they don't feel like it you know you
tell them you're bringing the camera out
if they have a problem with it you put
it away when they tell you to stop
shooting you stop shooting so you know
that's first and foremost I mean part of
the integrity I think comes from
treating everyone whether it's your
family or not with respect and dignity
and the golden rule and I personally
hate trying to make fun of anybody on
camera you know you're in this big power
advantage you know with them they're
they're trusting you with their with who
they are with their persona and with
their with their lives basically may
hate to sound so dramatic but they're
you know in a way opening up their lives
for you to interpret and there's a big
responsibility there and I think you
have to III think first and foremost you
need to be truthful I think most people
can take almost anything you put out
there as long as it's it's true truthful
I don't just mean accurate I mean true
to the spirit and your understanding of
who they are which in some cases means
you know in my wife's case you know I
did a very brief interview with her when
she was in the middle of a full-blown
depressive episode yeah that's in the
kids grow up and you know I I think she
was first of all you know uh I'm look
it's very difficult very difficult to
shoot i did it knowing that she would
want would have wanted it in there and
also knowing that she would see it first
and if she didn't want it it would out
it would go I mean she's very proud of
it now but part of my point is that it
doesn't necessarily mean showing people
in their best light but giving them you
know by the time I I was interested in
showing and Marjorie certainly was
interested in having presented that um
you know depression is just part of life
and it's not something to feel shame
Moore's stinking by stigmatized about
and so the more matter-of-factly its
treated and depicted in films
particularly ones that aren't really
about depression the more it goes away
as an issue the more comfortable people
are talking about it and the more
helpful it can be for others so you know
knowing that I shot it and and it was
very hard i can only bring myself to
shoot about two minutes worth virtually
all of it is in the finished film yes
very calm and she's very very proud of
being in there now yeah was very
powerful and and it was interesting to
that that those episodes yeah i think
she had talked about having three of
them but i always taken place before a
big life event of some some kind of
change so i thought that was fascinating
what's your take on time and on memories
you've done these films where you're
capturing snapshots of life um but
what's your stance on time well that's a
that's a very deep question how much
time do i have to think about it it's uh
yeah what I like about time i mean it is
fascinated to deal with on film and it's
the big advantage of being a documentary
filmmaker and particularly somebody
who's shot with my family
the years is you know it came time to do
a film about my daughter you know
something that I'd been thinking about
it as she was growing up but never could
really get a handle on until she was in
going into her senior of high school and
you know it it dawned on me how soon she
would be leaving and you know what I
realized that that really was kind of
the most dramatic and and and you know i
would say urgent part of parenting is
this whole process of letting go i
shouldn't say urgent but more more that
there hasn't been many films made about
it certainly not from a parent's point
of view i guess it's part of the beauty
of again living in this age of the
camcorder and that Lucy was born into it
and that I i was able over the years to
do a little bit of shooting all you know
regularly and over time it built into
quite a little archive of getting not
just you know the big moments as we
understand like graduations things like
that but birthdays but getting moments
like getting when she got her ears
pierced for the first time or when she
passed your driver's test some of the
less kind of recognized landmarks of
growing up and you know it's something
that documentary kit that can do that
fiction films can't I mean you know
fiction films can show somebody over
somebody's life over a 20-year period
but if if they were fit utilizing the
kids grow up they would be like three or
four different young actresses of
different ages playing Lucy and they may
be able to cast actresses who are you
know who look a lot alike and you go wow
they did such a good job of finding
finding these look-alikes but you know
seeing the documentary you know that's
her so that every time you go back and
forth in time there's a there's a
another layer of fascination of seeing
how she's changed
time and and going back into the past
and forms you know what you understand
about who she is in the present
particularly when she's being evasive in
the present so so it's fascinating to me
and you know similarly in 51 bird street
to go back and and dive into like
interviews that I did with my mother
who's no longer alive you know and be
able to to get her point of view and
tell the story partially from her point
of view as well so it wasn't all coming
from my father's perspective I'm doing a
film now where I you know I've helped
support my documentary work over the
past 15 years by shooting weddings yeah
I think I've shot about a counted 112 of
them and you know I've always wanted to
go back and you know see how some of my
favorite couples are doing and you know
what marriage is about and to be able to
juxtapose their you know their wedding
footage with where they now are 10 15
years later is just fascinating so when
will this project be finished well
hopefully well next year opening yeah I
mean we're it's mostly shot we're just
editing a fundraising sample now as we
speak and you know you look to raise the
money you do the editing you get it out
there you time it for like certain
wonderful film festivals and you hope
that you know it gets nicely launched
into the world and you don't have to do
it all yourself or put it up on YouTube
this is film courage we are on the line
with documentary filmmaker and founder
of the d-word com mr. Doug block join
the documentary film community at d
hyphen word calm and support Doug's work
by going to the kids grow up calm Doug
know you're talking about 51 bird street
you're also talking about getting films
out into the world and you're in you're
talking about film festivals let's start
with with 51 bird street which because
it was it was accepted into some major
film festivals what was the first film
festival That Bird Street got accepted
into
Toronto so the Toronto International
know how did you get into the toronto
international film festival i mean did
you did you have any pre-existing
relationships or ties to the festival uh
you know I knew I knew the person who
headed the documentary programming
vaguely uh Sean Farnell who who moved on
to Hot Docs until recently and
ironically a really good friend of mine
who I hung out that whole festival with
Tom powers the next year was named in
sean's place the director of the
documentary programming at the festival
so he didn't know no favors for me that
year I don't know you know we it's like
a lot of things you submit every
everybody seems to have this perception
I think that you need to know somebody
or you need to have this track record to
get accepted at a festival like Toronto
or Sundance or the like and you know I
think it doesn't hurt it can help but i
think i think festivals like that really
love to discover new talent and I give
them a lot of credit for every year
coming up with with really good new
films I mean you know I can tell you
first had because I'm executive producer
of resurrect dead the mystery of the
Toynbee tiles which opens in theaters on
September second I might add okay and is
actually online now at itunes and and
certain other VOD landing spots but I
you know the guy who made it John Foy
it's his first film he did you know he
did everything sort of backwards in the
wrong way he and you know did it all
himself over five year period basically
funding it out of his pocket you know
cleaning houses and living on food
stamps and things and I I actually got
on board because I might he's a d-word
member and he think it was like eve of
thanksgiving i got an email saying help
I just got into Sunday
and you know we got to talking and he
had submitted he'd been turned down from
a couple of festivals and he'd submitted
the Sundance on the very last day it
wasn't even going to do it but his
girlfriend said you know come on you'll
regret it he ran down burned it you know
deep burn to DVD ran down to fedex just
barely got it in over the transom and
here it was like a month and a half
later and he just got the call from
Sundance we love your film you're in the
US documentary competition he had no
idea what to do bags not at all had no
money but you know I think that's that
that's more of the case than people
suspect Sundance couldn't have been
happier that they had discovered this
really great new talent and he went on
by the way to win the direct Best
Director prize in the documentary
competition so you know I think there's
a lot to be said for just submitting
yeah I mean it's always happened with me
it's not like I call these festival
directors and say hi I submitted and
wink wink you know pick me yeah doesn't
work that way well do you submit
yourself or do you have an agent or
manager do it for you no I submit myself
okay I you don't usually get the sales
agent until you've gotten into Sundance
in Toronto then you get like 20 calling
yet I see uh chicken that doesn't quite
work the other way around so much I mean
you can but that's not usually the way
people go and I don't even think you
know I i think it's i really do think
it's overrated how much sales agents
help again yes it will put a film on
their radar but the film has to deliver
the goods I mean honestly how many how
many you know again I come from a
documentary background I think it's
different with certain established
fiction directors you know particularly
international directors you know they'll
get programmed it con just based on
their name but it doesn't work that way
in the dark world I mean I've I've
gotten turned down by Sundance plenty of
times you know some of the biggest
filmmakers have gotten turned down by
the bigger festival so you know what
happens all the time
yeah and coming back to the production
side of things when you were filming the
kids grow up I was it was it ever more
than just you with the camera I mean did
did you at did you ever have a film crew
with you know every now and then my
daughter grabbed the camera and turned
it on me miss just growing up but other
than that no I mean is that hard to film
your family you know with a crew and
it's a bit weird and is that how you
tend to work i mean do you tend to work
with just you in the camera my first of
all no although it was like a 2 i'd
never more than a three-person crew but
since then my lap the love you know the
last three films have all been made i
just find it you know I'm i like the
intimacy of shooting by myself you know
you know i'm going back to the wedding
couples now for the new film and you
know i mean i'd love to have a sound
person who could help me schlep the
equipment to and you know set up the the
light if we need one or something but i
just think it would completely change
the dynamic of the interview that
there's you know that's how they know me
that's how i shoot my wedding films is
this it's just me it's not a crew you
know we're not turning this into
production I am a fly on the wall
following you on your wedding day you
know and I hope they ignore me as best
they can and you know likewise you know
in these kinds of films that are you
know meant to be intimate and and and
come from a first-person perspective I
just don't see how I could have another
person in the room with me much as I'd
love to you know I hate humping all that
equipment you know it's just really you
know I'm getting too old I mean and do
you think that that has a large part or
you know that it plays a large part and
just the authenticity you see and in the
films that you've made you know and I
did will be really I think it shows up
on the screen i think you know i mean i
try i think we're might experience come
and from having shot so many years is
you know I still try and make it look
really good as good as I possibly can
and I do pay attention to where is the
light coming from and how is it falling
on their face and you know try and get
good compositions and things like that
so you know part of my brain is going
there and the other part of my brain is
trying to you know I'm not a performer
but I'm often in the films as a
character you know it's coming from my
personal experience whether I'm on
camera or not and I try not to be on
camera that often really but I just
think there's something really important
about the kind of energy and and dynamic
that you have of just shooting as one
person and ever having people look into
the camera lens as opposed to looking
off-screen at a you know at a invisible
interviewer from off-camera as a
cameraman as a guy who worked you know
in beginning as the Cameron for other
documentaries and other documentary like
you know news features and things like
that you know working with many many
different producers it always struck me
as very strange that conceit of having
the interviewer be slightly off camera
and seeing somebody look you know
slightly to the right or left of the Lev
of the lens you know I you know you
don't really sit and analyze it much but
you know as a camera person i did for
years like those like why is this you
know why can't we just look right at the
camera that i think there's something
more direct and powerful about it so you
know immediately when i started making
my own films i wanted to have that that
kind of relationship between the the
camera and the subject now with 51 birch
Street I believe you released it in
2005-2006 and with the kids grow up
2009-2010 how did the path to
distribution differ for these two films
very good question you know we're with
50 on birch Street we were all still in
the mode that you go to a Toronto and
you have a sales agent
and you try and create a bidding war and
we came really close I mean there was a
lot of interest but you know I it was a
it was well there any number of reasons
why it just didn't happen but now you
know when by the time the kids grow up
came out it wasn't realistic to think
that way about documentaries anymore i
mean the market had changed it was a you
know Eve just getting any kind of bigger
distributor for your film was near
impossible for your doc for a
documentary much less create any kind of
bidding war and it was much more
realistic to to use what you know do it
what's known as a service deal where you
actually pay the distributor a fee to
book the films into theaters and collect
the money and do some of the other
things that distributors do and you as
the producer separate out the rights you
know you hold on to your DVD and your TV
rights and your international rights and
your VOD rights and all that sort of
stuff it's much more viable way of
making a return on your film any kind of
return on your film so that's that's the
big difference is that we weren't you
know we didn't we didn't go with the
sales agent for the kids grow up we got
some good advice you know but basically
we went out we went right after the
service deals no part of it is that we
I've gotten funding from broadcasters
that's how I've gotten these films made
is that they're you know essentially
co-productions with HBO and a number of
international broadcasters we had four
altogether when the kids grow up so when
you have your TV sales pre-made you know
when you go into distribution having
particularly having a US television
presale in place it's it's far more
difficult to get a traditional
distributor
because they count on having the US TV
sale offset you know what they consider
a loss leader of theatrical distribution
mm so it's not as enticing for them so
you know the bigger distributors don't
want it because they just don't care
about smaller documentaries anymore and
you know there's corporate stuff
involved too because HBO is owned by
Time Warner which is a corporate rival
let's say if Sony Pictures Classics you
know so that eliminates them and a
couple of others so you know by the end
of the day you're you're left with
basically hiring a distributor and
that's what you do and so more and more
you try and actually build that into
your budget and you know understand that
when your film is done you better not be
running out of money because you may not
be able to get it out into the world at
what point did you approach HBO like how
did you get HBO involved and behind this
film um well I'd work with them on a
couple of other films but you know
they've also turned me down on projects
I've come to them with that so you know
again it's a case by case basis and um
you know I I think the only thing that
having a track record and a successful
track record with HBO has done is you
know when I bring new projects to them I
get to hear no sooner you know they have
a pile of about a hundred thousand DVDs
that have come in with samples that
works in progress samples and that's
just that week and no says a lot to be
said for you know when I bring it to
them they watch fairly quickly and I and
I get a yes or no pretty quickly but
it's all it's all based on the sample
you know the sample has to deliver they
don't even want to hear what it's about
basically other than a sentence or two
they don't want to see anything written
they don't want God knows they don't
want to see a budget you know Sheila
Nevins when she gets to it you know when
when when all the people who are you
know working for her you know and are
kind of the barriers to her you know our
gotten through you know you've gotten to
the person who can bring it to Sheila
yeah she's gonna put it in her or DVD
player hmm and just really want to know
anything about it she just wants to see
what's there and see that it's a good
story with really you know really
interesting characters and kind of an
you know get a sense of what the arc of
the story is and she'll either go you
know kind of thumbs up or both mostly
thumbs down so it's really sorry case by
case we'd like to talk about the
formation of the D word now believe that
it was born out of your blog and I think
you mentioned previously that you felt
your blog was sort of just this one way
sort of platform where you were speaking
to people but there was no real
communication happening back you tell us
about the formation sure um yeah it's a
little confusing because you know my
blog now is called that confusing name
how was it again committed it to memory
blocks doc blog anyway uh the D word
actually was my initial blog I mean it
when it came out as a result of this
film homepage which is the first time i
worked with HBO and it was about the
Internet's first blogger you go to
Wikipedia and he's now considered the
first blogger and I wound up you know
kind of out of empathy for him and
wanting to understand how it's done
creating my own blog unlike him I didn't
write about my sex life fascinating than
it was and remains hug that you know I
did wind up writing about the process of
making the film and I kept it up for
four years and like you said yeah Karen
it's like it is kind of a one-way
platform that gets tiring after a while
getting up on your soap box and speaking
to the masses and they're not very
masked to begin with and so you know was
kind of get with the distribution phase
of the film was winding down I was
speaking to a friend who's very big on
virtual communities and I'd gotten to
know what that was like a little bit
from the film
i I just casually mentioned that but you
know bout documentary documentary
filmmakers would make such a great
virtual community when there's such a
you know they're they're great people
and they're really good about sharing
information and God knows we all work in
isolation even in new york city we're
kind of like you know go into our edit
rooms for a year at a time and barely
poke our nose out and i just thought
this would make a great you know make
for a great community online and he said
down it's far easier than you think and
not even all that expensive and kind of
as a lark we actually put it up the next
day and that was over 12 years ago and
you know we never really promoted or
advertise it i'm glad you brought it up
but you know i probably wouldn't even
have mentioned it had I been on here you
know without you bringing it up and and
and yet it's grown to over 8,500
registered members from a hundred and
seventeen countries Wow and it's really
active in thriving and know as proud as
I am of my films I will never be prouder
of anything that I've ever done then
then creating this community online I
mean because you know you were doing
this before you know people were
tweeting and putting stuff on Facebook I
mean did you ever do any kind of SEO or
anything like that to grow it or just
sort of was this organic thing that
happened what's an SEO all of these
these things to you know increase its
answered your IC so it just sort of you
your love for it and and and that
passion spread other pew know what
happened I mean like a first week
they're a bunch of geeky guys on there
and then two really wonderful great
women got on the second week and started
writing and like all of a sudden our
numbers like triple you know within a
day and I mean I think we were just
waiting for for a kind of interaction to
take place and like the fire just
ignited very quickly and and it just
keeps burning you know but it's just a
kind of word of mouth
phenomena it's just always been and
always will be I think and you know
frankly I was never really interested in
the numbers you know we haven't even
figured out a way to monetize it yet
it's it's free has been probably always
will be probably I reserve the right to
change that though um you know what I
think it's just attracted an amazing
community of people who happen to make
documentaries but are are you know
really engaged in the world and who are
you know very generous warm wonderful
people and so you know we we talk a lot
about documentary and all things
documentary but there's a lot of talk
beyond that just about the world at
large and our place in it and why we do
what we do when there's no money in it
mm-hmm you know and then that's a great
way to sort of conclude this
conversation oh it's depressing I know I
know you know because we want to be able
to go more into a great folks but really
it's such a great way to spend your life
now very nice you know Doug we want to
thank you for a first for coming on film
kurz today oh my pleasure we've really
enjoyed this conversation so yummy to
thank you thanks so much for having me
thank you you've been speaking with doug
block documentary filmmaker and founder
of the D word community a site for
documentary filmmakers which he founded
in nineteen ninety nine for more on Doug
block please visit his amazing site d
hyphen word com which we were just
talking about you can also visit the
kids grow up com Doug block weddings com
at Doug block on Twitter and at the kids
go up on Twitter Facebook and
facebook.com slash the kids grow up and
and and thank you so much Doug once
again for sharing on your time we're
gonna sort of release you back to
editing yeah you know dug dugs calling
us from the editing room today and thank
you for joining us on another edition of
film courage and we look forward to
being here with you next sunday at noon
on la talk radio com where we will be
joined by film
acre and musician Stephen Moore Marco to
talk about his film the great
intervention I mean you can check out an
article that Stephen wrote where he's
naked and has peanut butter on his
nipples on on our website and that
article is called fud zoloft to make
indie film but just know that we warned
you but you know you're going to be your
life will forever be impacted for more
information on Stephen Moore Marco
please visit great intervention dot info
and until sunday i have for every week